[Music]
foreign
food so there'll be General rejoicing in
the house because my kids absolutely
love it whether it's Asian noodles
Mexican tacos or even American Fried
Chicken trust me street food is fast to
serve fun and packed with flavor and
that's what makes it so easy to cook at
home first up for breakfast a classic
from the streets of India decided to be
eaten on the go but brilliant devout in
the comfort of your own kitchen
incredible Indian spiced egg and spinach
wrap what smells incredible next is
lunch and my take on two street food
Essentials perfect prawn tostadas and
salted caramel popcorn that's impossible
to resist beautiful for dinner my son
jack helps cook one of his all-time
favorites
nice nice see that doesn't have any
chest boom it's working already
home-cooked street food that will have
everyone racing indoors to sit down and
eat delicious dolce de leche biscuits
quick sweet pickled celery and amazing
buttermilk fried chicken I love fried
chicken I love it more than you did this
is my ultimate street food breakfast
lunch and dinner first up it's breakfast
and eggs guaranteed to spice up your day
some of the best food I had in India was
to treat food and every little food
still was cooking up something spicy
something delicious a little teaspoon of
oil toast off
a teaspoon of cumin mustard seeds
Touch of salt
and pepper
lightly fry them off
it's really important to cook off the
spices it intensifies the flavor but
really draws out that nice spicy deep
rich flavor so
onion three fingers one in front two
behind nice and fine
onions in
now
we've got caramelize those onions
mustard seeds have started to infuse
cumin has that nice kick
now with a little touch of butter in
there
get it nice and sort of Rich gas up nice
and high and really caramelize those
onions now once the onions have turned a
rich golden color that's what I'm
looking for that is beautiful ADD baby
spinach
keep that pan nice and hot if you don't
cook it out the actual breakfast ends up
watery when the spinach is cooked set
aside and it's on to the spicy eggs
now the breakfast really starts to come
alive four nice eggs
foreign
[Music]
into the pan a little teaspoon
of oil so the butter doesn't burn when
the butter and oil are hot add a
teaspoon of garam masala and turmeric
to grill out
now take your eggs
into the pan
almost gonna make like a really nice
spicy scrambled egg turn the gas down
now because the scrambled egg comes
together
just finish that with a little bit of
butter
I quite like the sort of creaminess
makes it so much more delicious
and then from there
let me get my spinach
chop up
and then fold in
the spinach
to a scrambled egg
something quite exciting about eating
spice for breakfast but it's served in
these wonderful little
Phenom breads this will work with any
flatbread or wrap you fancy and then
lightly toast your naan take the eggs
off the heat whilst you get on with the
last job add quick mint and spiced
yogurt dressing
a couple of tablespoons
of fresh yogurt in there's always
something to take out the heat then add
chopped mint salt and turmeric
mix that in
ah take
scrambled egg and half fill
Phenom it smells incredible get your
yogurt
put it down on top and lift that over
and for me that's what really stands out
with street food in India
how delicious they can make street food
with a little bit of spice
amazing
[Music]
try this spicy wrap I promise you
scrambled eggs will never taste the same
coming up I'll be showing you some
irresistible street food dishes that are
brilliant cooked at home
but first here's a closer look at some
of the ingredients you'll need to buy to
make them starting with tortillas for
lunch
when it comes to street food the
Mexicans have got it nailed tortillas
turn any dish into a portable Feast
the yellow ones are made from corn flour
white ones from wheat
I'm going to toast a wheat tortilla for
the incredible prawn tostada I'm making
for lunch
[Music]
paprika originates in Hungary where it's
been sold on the streets for half a
millennia
made from dried ground Peppers ranging
from sweet bell to mild chili peppers it
could be sweet or hot but it's the
incredible smoked paprika I'm using for
my secret fried chicken recipe
everyone loves popcorn and it's
incredibly easy to make
it's just the dried kernels from calling
the cob it comes in loads of different
colors and varieties
good old yellow is the one we know and
love whilst red is slightly nuttier and
white gives a fluffier mild flavored
corn taste
on the menu next for lunch is my take on
this street food classic
one of the reasons I love cooking street
food at home is because it's such a
contrast to what I do in my mission
style restaurants on a daily basis
it's not about intricacy or complexity
that's all gone out the window and trust
me there's only one rule if it tastes
great cook it here's my ultimate street
food lunch succulent zingy prawn
tostadas and for dessert salty caramel
popcorn so good you'll want to eat it by
the handful
you can't beat
properly home-cooked popcorn
start off with just a touch
of oil in there as it lightly starts to
smoke
corn in
so now get your lid never leave it far
away from you
sounds like it's raining it's not
so it's popcorn Canal it's time to pop
out
boom
let's just just a little Shake of the
pan
get it going
and then lift that lid
at your peril
wait
see
it's a very exciting pan in there
I mean all that little pitter patter
stops you know your popcorn is cut
nice
fresh from the pan but I've got another
plan
I'm gonna make a salted caramel popcorn
start off with your sugar into the hot
pan
never stir a camera otherwise it
crystallizes it's a salted caramel so a
nice pinch of salt in there as well
now once you've got it to a really nice
dark caramel flavor stir in your butter
very carefully caramel is very very hot
half a teaspoon of bicarbonate of soda
kick-starts the reaction that gives the
caramel a honeycomb flavor mix that in
you'll see it
reacting
almost like a large crunchy in the
bottom of your bowl
now the gas is off and that camo is a
nice dark rich flavor
now pour in the popcorn to coat it with
that incredible caramel give that a good
mix
it's that easy and it's going to taste
amazing
lay that nice and flat
once that cools down it becomes nice and
brittle we've got that nice salted
caramel flavor which just takes popcorn
to completely level whilst the popcorn
cools down it's onto my prawn tostada
wonderful prawns
I'm gonna marinate them first with a
little bit of garlic
nice and fine
and don't worry if you can't slice
thinly just
get a little greater and Grate the
garlic nice and fine as well nice pinch
of chili flakes over your prawn garlic
in
salt pepper
and olive oil give that a really nice
little mix whilst the prawns marinade
I'm going to knock up a salad this is a
really nice sort of light fragrant salad
radishes topped and tailed and then into
quarters
Joe tomatoes halved
spring onions sliced and seasoned
and then just to liven things up a
little bit of chili in there and slice
them on an angle
now the avocado cut in half
give that a little twist
so you just go down
and down and down carefully with your
knife turn it round
go down and down and down and then
you take your spoon you've got your
diced avocado
coming out already
now baby gem lettuce half then Shred
freshly squeezed lime juice a little
drizzle
of olive oil just out as a classic
Mexican style open tortilla so that lime
complements it beautifully lastly
roughly chopped coriander and give it a
mix that is the perfect base
for a tostada the salad's ready now for
the prawns and don't be afraid of
getting pan nice and hot
teaspoon of olive oil in
anything less than that Sizzle when you
put that first prawn in there don't put
them in keep them nice and flat
make sure you've got all that marinade
in there as well watch them change color
more rapidly I'd rather cook them
quicker in a hotter pan and slower in a
colder Pan the difference in taste is
night and day the prawns will take just
two minutes to cook through lime juice
just over the top nice
got some over the line
these are corned tortilla quite robust
and it's the kind of Base that doesn't
disintegrate hot pan in it's a dry pan
so that corn tortilla goes nice and
crisp on the outside
[Music]
crispy shell to build them generous with
the salad
That Base will stay nice and crisp
next with your prawns I like to keep the
tails in to the center and lay the round
part of the prawn on the outside and
there we have a delicious yeah very
humble prawn tostada followed by my
superb salty camel popcorn
beautiful
[Music]
prawn tostadas and salty caramel popcorn
vibrant irresistible smelling dishes
you'll want to dive into
over the past 20 years I've really
noticed a big change in people's
attitude to what they will and won't eat
these days people are much more
adventurous they love trying new flavors
new ingredients and new cooking
techniques
whether it's cooked on the street or in
your home kitchen this is my ultimate
finger licking street food dinner
[Music]
and helping me in the kitchen to make
one of his all-time favorites is my son
jack
first job the perfect side dish for my
fantastic Fried Chicken
Jack hi am I gonna help with some piglet
please oh definitely no you love pickles
right I love pickles um favorite pickle
what is it I like pickled onions we're
gonna do pickled celery this is a nice
little snack and great for plant ones
great for salads first thing I'm going
to pick the celery for me so you see
where the next one's gonna be it's in
there yeah okay I'll figure one
doggy today is this all we're having for
dinner Jack come on I wouldn't do that
too you know that there's more coming
now because we're picking it we want to
sort of make it look a little bit more
attractive so we go around like that
okay on an angle so when you pick all
the food does it does it preserve it
that's exactly what it does but also
gives it a really nice salty soury
flavor yeah okay now a splash of water
and then with the sugar nice okay
so you've got to bring that up to the
ball to sort of crate almost like a
little syrup yeah okay A little teaspoon
of Peppercorns in mustard seeds in quite
generous on the mustard seeds that gives
a bit of sort of spice now those as you
must know
clothes excellent clothes
and now touch the salt in there okay
so from there white wine vinegar now in
order for all that to actually
pickle you need to boil it so by boiling
it okay it brings all ingredients
together it chooses all the spices
and
helps cook the celery have a little
taste
nice nice see I put some has on your
chest
yes it will look boom it's working
already now see hmm
nice
vinegar right celery is ready yep okay
let's go up to the ball now
yeah turn that off
now from there
start placing the celery into that jar
so when you pick one other foods can you
use that same recipe exactly that
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off okay now put them in there so can we
eat this straight away when it's in here
do you know what as soon as it's cooled
down
you can definitely eat that straight
away I can't wait to dig into it only
delicious
yeah we'll leave that to cool down our
pickles are ready and cooling now to
marinate the chicken on the Fried
Chicken traditionally it's always going
to be done with the dark meat the brown
meat so you've got that nice sort of
drum here and this bit yeah that thigh
cooking on the bone as well keeps it
even more moist so first things first
Salt and Pepper please
buttermilk buttermilk in it's brilliant
for marinating the chicken if you can
put this buttermilk over your chicken
the night before the more it tenderizes
the chicken and starts to sort of really
relax the chicken and puts a really nice
sort of creamy soury flavor in there so
I might stick that in the fridge for us
please and we'll start the dolce de
leche biscuits
call these shortbreads Alpha Jorge and
they're the favorite sweet treat on the
streets of Buenos Aires they're light
crumbly shortbread biscuits sandwiched
with gloriously golden cowly dolce de
leche sauce
for the shortbread beat together
softened butter
granulated sugar
and beat until light and fluffy
add one egg
[Music]
slice vanilla pots grape out the seeds
add to the mix
and beat again
[Music]
sift plain flour corn flour
and baking powder then fold the mixture
together
using floured hands roll into small
balls flatten into discs and place on a
baking tray
and chill for 10 minutes until firm to
touch then simply bake for 10 to 12
minutes or until pale golden
once cooled sandwich two biscuits
together with a calmly dolce de leche
sauce
[Music]
finish with a dusting of icing sugar
delicious
my dessert and pickles are ready the
buttermilk should have worked its magic
on the chicken all that's left is to fry
it
now we're gonna roll the chicken out of
the buttermilk into the flour so that's
why it gets nice and crispy and blistery
on the outside Okay cool so what we've
got to make sure because the flour is
the last coat yes this is nicely
seasoned yeah okay so salt and pepper in
there
nice
and this is smoked paprika so that gives
it a little bit of sort of uh maybe it's
yeah yeah spice let's try a little bit
of heat and this one my favorites what's
that cayenne pepper that's right again
slightly spicy but the heat works
brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally I used a lot
in the steaks onion powder garlic powder
just run your fingers through that
please only get the pan on now
two centimeters of oil this is a really
good mix for fish as well goojons biting
a nice spicy
texture helps fish so first thing is we
just shake off some of the buttermilk
lay that down yeah okay really important
to get them covered completely okay in
the flour yeah okay so I love fried
chicken do you
now lift that up there first one and you
place it in there away from you off it
yeah nice and gently
good and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yeah just add a touch of
cold oil in there yeah or turn off the
gas
good gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through now very
carefully turn them over please yeah
Jack Fried Chicken every day no
definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so once every three weeks
yeah sounds great to me yeah now offer
the gas okay yeah paper ready okay onto
the paper
foreign
delicious now
Fried Chicken
at pickles if you pick up um adult
electric cakes we are ready bud
very nice
delicious
mom
Divine dolce de leche biscuits my
pickled celery and buttermilk fried
chicken A Soulful street food Feast if
there ever was one
and join the Ramsey Clan tonight is
Tilly's schoolmate Phoebe
now first of all we have some very very
exciting pickled celery Phoebe and I'll
have a drum please nice ladies you can
lift up with your fingers especially on
the drums
finger licking chicken that's right
Phoebe how's the chicken amazing I won't
be able to like make this at all yes you
would yes you will it's so easy to meet
you soon so it's very easy to make mine
yeah Dad did say we could have it every
night in the week what I said as a treat
it's chicken so it's healthy right you
don't always take you always tell me
tell me every night okay there are loads
more great home cooking recipes on my
app cook with me you can find it in the
App Store good luck
what's Phoebe's favorite show tell me
please
um well sometimes I watch Jamie Oliver's
15 minute meal
sometimes you watch Jamie Oliver's
15-Minute Meals
I love a great party but I hate bad food
and often the two things go together I
think one of the reasons is that home
Cooks get intimidated by the thought of
cooking for large crowds so they give up
and serve shop walk food instead but
trust me with a bit of planning and
great recipes it's easy this is my
ultimate part of food first up a great
brunch for a crowd spicy Mexican eggs
for a sophisticated party lunch you can
pre-prepare beetroot cured salmon and a
chocolate mint cake little sheets of
glass beautiful my eldest daughter Megan
will be helping me rustle up some
amazing dishes for a relaxed Ramsay
get-together that's okay with
irresistible Smoky pulled pork don't
tell mum thank you
simple but delicious sides of broccoli
slaw and crushed potatoes with spring
onions and gruya cheese
I've never had this before it's so good
these are my ultimate party recipes that
will entertain and sustain a house full
of guests for breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with the breakfast that can't
fail to get your guests fired up and
ready to party spicy Mexican eggs
this is a very classic Mexican style
brunch dish bold Kick-Ass flavors slice
the chili seeds in
garlic sliced nice and thinly
tablespoon of olive oil
I'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch you can see
you're right through to dinner now to
start the sort of spicy fragrant tomato
sauce get your cumin in there
garlic chili roasted cumin red onions
already sounds Mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with your tomatoes
that are embarrassed using good canned
tomatoes I do all the time cooking at
home
Now by reducing that sort of come down
to a delicious paste leave that to
simmer
next canned beans called black beans
these are authentically Mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine just rinse them a little bit
of water
that is beautiful turn off the gas and
just let it absorb leaving the dense
beans to luxuriate in the spicy tomato
sauce will allow them to soften and soak
up all the flavor
next oil and season an oven proof dish
for my spicy egg brunch to baking
I'll just get some of that oil
around the outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half and then just stick them to the
side
bees are a staple in Mexico
take one replace that in the center
get your mix and place that on top of
the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little flaps I want that crisp
shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just make a little hole in
there and then crack
the egg into the
again use a little point
put your egg in there one
two
three
four five
and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like it's a little dug out
and then one for the center
it's got a really nice rich delicious
strong Montgomery cheddar I want a grape
the tortilla shell as well so get
generous with it on the top and we'll
season that with these little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg just salt
a touch of pepper
sit that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible
it's a little bit of coriander to finish
it off and that for me is what brunch is
all about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started spicy Mexican eggs and a
crispy tortilla shell
[Music]
coming up my ultimate food for lunch or
evening party
but first here's a closer look at the
key ingredients you'll need and a few
pointers on what to look for when you're
buying them
[Music]
chocolate the ultimate comfort food
addictive and indulgent the chocolate
making process begins by grinding
roasted cocoa beans
quality chocolate should contain at
least 70 cocoa solids it should give a
distinctive crisp snap when broken and
start melting in your hand after just a
few seconds
and there'll be no skimping on the
quality for my party lunch chocolate
mint cake
pork shoulder is an easy to cook flavor
some joints and can be bought on the
bone or rolled it's relatively cheap
price makes it a great choice when
you're feeding a crowd marbled with fat
to keep it moisture and cooking it's
also the cut of choice for barbecue
pulled pork known effectively in the U.S
as Boston butts I'll be cooking my
delicious version of this meltingly good
export as the star guest on my dinner
party
[Applause]
sodium chloride or salt is a mineral
essential to human life it's also one of
the most widely used seasonings in the
world it's lack of Aroma belies its
strong taste which both enhances the
natural flavor of food and stimulates
our taste buds this seasoning of all
seasonings is processed in various ways
and comes in all different colors and
forms but for me the finest in flavor is
crystallized sea salt the product of
evaporated seawater and is what I'll be
using to cure my salmon the main course
for my super simple but spectacular
party lunch
I think the best dishes for lunch
parties are the things that everyone can
help themselves too I also prefer dishes
that pack a really big flavor punch and
look impressive party food shouldn't be
subtle here are a couple of dishes for
my ultimate lunch party
the secret behind during salmon is in
the flavoring you're curing it with for
a hint of the Exotic and aromatic my
favorite starting point is to grind
coriander seeds
coriander seeds are citrusy it's got
that nice orangey flavor and it goes
brilliantly well with salmon
mix that with your salt and your sugar
it may look like a lot of salt and sugar
but once they've done their job of cold
cooking or curing the salmon most of it
will be washed away
next the greatest zest of two oranges
fresh pepper
and then mix in one of my favorite
ingredients grated beetroot
beetroot gives us a really nice sort of
Rooty earthy flavor great for curing it
stains the salmon as well and it just
elevates it
now you'll see what's happening now with
a beetroot the salt and sugar breaking
it down see how wet it's becoming now
that beetroot is ready for the salmon
if you've got a big party 10 or 20. you
get a whole side of salmon fill it and
get it pin boned by a fishmonger if it's
six or ten guests then this Chunk in the
middle is like the sort of middle part
of a fillet steak The Best of the Best
pour on your beetroot and basically what
we're going to do now is sort of pack it
with all the beetroot and look at that I
mean it looks fantastic
next cover your beet Rooty salmon with
climb film take your tray
lightly press and they get something
substantial something heavy a pot
a pan or some tins the weight on top
just speeds up the process
[Music]
in the fridge to cure for at least eight
hours or even better overnight
[Music]
to follow my deliciously light and
simple salmon
a devilishly indulgent dessert nothing
beats a great cake a sort of a show-off
trophy for party foods I'm going to make
the most amazing flourless chocolate
cake but with a Twist first thing first
make the caramel flatten the sugar never
stir a caramel rule number one now keep
the pan nice and flat
I'm going to flavor this caramel with a
little bit of mint give it a little chop
sprinkle that into the caramel
don't get the caramel too dark just nice
and light a little teaspoon of oil onto
the tray and rub that in
and then pour out
your camera if I was making a caramel
sauce then I'd put butter and cream into
the caramel but I want this nice minted
brittle running through my cake whilst
the candle cools down on a tray I'm
gonna make my cake
first melt good quality dark chocolate
in a bammary
eating it directly in the pan would
destroy the cocoa fats always in a bowl
over boiling water in a mixing bowl
sugar two whole eggs and three egg yolks
whisk until beautifully light and creamy
and the color changes to a light yellow
the more you mix the eggs and the sugar
the lighter that texture in the center
of the chocolate cake next melt some
butter into your warm dark chocolate and
stir puts that really nice Sheen velvety
rich and tasting amazing add that to
your sugar and your eggs
hmm
I give that a really good mix
and when you're making flourless
desserts it really is important to work
harder incorporating air especially with
the yolks and the sugar that natural
height needs to take place at the
beginning look at that it's like the
perfect chocolate ganache
then separate four egg whites into a
bowl
[Music]
now make sure you've got two thirds of
the way there with your whites and then
just sprinkle in your sugar it's almost
like a meringue and the firmer you make
these now the more it will elevate your
cake in the oven
foreign
[Music]
that's what you call a stiff peak
in with the whites
before I start mixing that I'll get my
camera
just start breaking that up it's a
little glass sheets of glass beautiful
and save some of your minty camel shards
for decoration and use a rolling pin to
break up the rest into small pieces
sprinkle that in
so as we start to slice that chocolate
cake you'll come across that nice crunch
take your cake tin
make sure it's lined with the grease
with paper
on the bottom nicely greased pour this
in
sharp Taps on a hard surface or rid your
cake mixture of any air pockets that
could create holes in your cake
sit that in the oven
180.
after 35 minutes my chocolate mint cake
is cooked and whilst it cools down I can
whip up a peppermint cream topping
[Music]
add sifted icing sugar and a few drops
of peppermint extract to double cream
and whisk until it's just holding its
shape
[Music]
spoon your minty cream on top of the
cake leaving a small border free to make
it easier to cut for a cake that can't
fail to attract attention at your party
scatter over the remaining caramel mint
shards
[Music]
now to unveil my incredible beetroot
cured salmon
offer the weight
that's right
and love what's happened to the salmon
absolutely beautiful
and just tell how delicious that's going
to be with this sort of Sheen give that
a little rinse and cold water
with your kitchen roll Pat it nice and
dry
beautiful
traditionally cured salmon would be
sliced into large thin pieces like
smoked salmon but I like to cut mine
Into Thin strips it's easier and it will
show off its beauty
slice down get to the skin and then
flick your knife out
that for me is a much better way of
eating cured salmon
look at the difference the colors that
nice dark Rich ruby red
now when you've got cured salmon this
good trust me you just need a salad
melbour toast or some stunning bread
look how many slices of salmon we've got
Master secret for me to any good party a
couple masterpieces simple
straightforward ingredients but done
properly
foreign
[Music]
cured salmon and for dessert a Divine
chocolate mint cake party food with the
wow factor
[Music]
when you work in a restaurant your job
is to make sure people have a great time
you're there to make sure they're
enjoying themselves believe me after 20
odd years in the business I've got
experience in this department and the
golden rule for successes don't get
intimidated get organized here are three
of my ultimate dishes for a great
evening party
[Music]
if there's one thing all the Ramsay
children love it's a good family party
and my eldest Megan is going to help me
with the party piece
mouth-watering Smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise
[Music]
that is the most amazing pork butt
butts away butts away now this is
incredible there's the shoulder yeah and
look there's the shoulder blade if you
go through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's cool but the slower you cook it the
more juice it is and it's great for big
parties because you just come along and
get your fork and shred it a delicious
Smoky mayonnaise and you're away onions
into half and half again okay I'm Gonna
Leave the roots on okay because I want
this to sit underneath the port
it gives a chance to cook evenly it
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay now I'll peel the garlic
okay I'd like you and to crush the
garlic we're gonna make a really nice
little paste
okay
come on Mickey
come on come on come on nice good girl
one more Crush
come on Mickey
oh sorry
cut there now this
is a beauty
paprika smoke paprika I love it so three
nice tablespoons in
okay two large tablespoons of brown
sugar
salt place and pepper
[Laughter]
so I'm going to form a nice paste now
olive oil in
what's that I want some thyme in there
so we got a sort of fragrant rub time
stalks
underneath
so that's even more flavor going on the
bottom
pour that all over it
now this is where you've got to be
really quick
okay
rub that massage it in almost that's
exactly that
smells amazing we'll see just drizzle a
little touch of olive oil on top of that
for me
I keep the pork nice and moist
lovely like some of the best party
dishes the marinating the pork shoulder
can be done days in advance so if I was
doing this for a Sunday and start
marinating Thursday Friday so it gets
even tastier right it's quite easy as
well to make it's very easy five and a
half to six hours in the oven at 140.
while I pork butt slowly roast Meg and I
are gonna prep some shop bought
mayonnaise I don't like just plain
mayonnaise there's so many things you
can twist yeah there's so many things so
many exciting you can do with it right
salt pepper and
no touch of Honey sweetness sweetness
but there's some heat coming okay and
I've got a little bit of you know this
Chipotle smoked Chipotle paste I love
that once you've made this dressing you
know it can sit in the fridge great for
open sandwiches yeah can you use it for
any sandwiches really any sandwiches but
goes brilliantly well with pork now just
have a little taste
a nice spoon of mustard
so that's a nice spicy mayonnaise
after five and a half hours in the oven
our pork is nearly ready just time to
knock up a couple of tried and tested
party favorites first deliciously simple
cheesy crushed potatoes
cut potatoes into even chunks and
submerge in salted boiling water skins
and all
meanwhile finely diced sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons
trim and finely chopped spring onions
and Grate some nutty gruya cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
season to taste and gently combined
before a final sprinkling of grated
Greer
potatoes are equally delicious served
hot or cold
now I want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing yeah so
I'm going to make a really nice fresh
broccoli salad now these are called
florets that's the best part of the
broccoli okay the bit everybody wants
once they're off I'm going to slice the
broccoli
okay never had raw broccoli before it's
always been cooked when you dress this
with the dressing it's incredible now
little Seasons early on
yeah okay now for the dressing fresh
yogurt in teaspoon of sugar please die
a little small
cider vinegar there you go
finely chopped shallot
in with a broccoli so
delicious
roasted almonds into the broccoli
carrots I love them that gives that nice
sort of chewy texture right lift up your
bowl please nice and gently
half of that in the middle please thank
you and stop and then mix that up with
me okay
a little taste
so good and it's kind of salad that
doesn't Wilt a couple of hours later
it's still crunchy because the
broccoli's raw raw broccoli salad
Chipotle now let me get a pork out for
this look at this Megan honestly that is
amazing it's beautiful that is
incredible
[Music]
now that goes to the table like that a
delicious
before we go to the table oh my God just
a little bit honestly
don't tell mum thank you awesome
can I do it I'm gonna do it
so good you promised me you don't give
the recipe to your boyfriend let's go
[Music]
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt in your mouth slow cooked Smoky
pulled pork with a spicy chipoli
mayonnaise
I'm quick simple size of crushed cheesy
potatoes and a light and healthy
broccoli slaw deliciously yummy dishes
that will have your family friends and
work buddies coming back for more right
[Music]
I love the chocolates
wow the sauce is a bit spicy dad nearly
blew my head off
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
foreign